- Our next speaker is Susan Mizner.
Susan is Disability Counsel from
the ACLU here in San Francisco,
and is back by popular demand
to hear more about
supported decision making,
civil liberties and
alternatives to conservatorship,
to guardianship.
Thank you so much for
being here today, Susan.
- And this stool is my
reasonable accommodation.
Thank you to Gerry and
Lucy for the invitation,
it's really lovely to be here.
How do I work this?
I just go forward. Got it.
Okay. Is someone else
gonna turn these for me?
Will you move them forward for me?
- You just push this right here.
Forward, reverse.
- Okay, great. Thank you.
I'm in control. I like that.
(audience laughs)
Giving you your workout for the day.
(applause)
The thing that I take off of my bio
is that I'm a graduate
of Yale and Stanford,
and this is exactly why.
We're gonna cover the three...
Yes, there we go.
The three main issues
that we're covering today
are the problems with conservatorships,
the promise of supported decision-making,
and then going beyond the binary
in trying to do competency evaluations.
The first two, I'm hoping,
are a bit of a review
but I want to ask first,
how many of you have worked
with people under conservatorship?
A lot. Okay.
How many of you have done
competency evaluations?
A smaller number. All right.
And then, how many of you know
what supported decision-making is?
Pretty good.
And how many of you have practiced
supported decision-making
in your practice?
Okay, it's probably more of
you than who raised your hands,
but we'll go over that.
Let's talk about what
conservatorship is, first.
It's a legal process, right?
You have the court,
you have an individual with a disability,
and the court appoints someone else
to be making decisions
for that individual.
The legal standard for doing that
is that the individual is unable to
provide for his or her personal needs,
being able to provide
food, clothing, shelter,
even with supports,
that's important,
and also important, there are no
less restrictive options available.
I'm forgetting to do this.
You're moving these for
me, aren't you? Okay.
(audience laughs)
The conservator controls
essentially everything
when it is a plenary conservatorship.
There are conservatorships that
are supposed to be more restrictive,
that they only control a
certain part of someone's life.
But even after decades
of advocacy to improve
the way we implement conservatorships,
we find that that
generally doesn't happen.
That plenary conservatorships are the
default mode for most judges.
It's understandable.
They're worried about what would happen
if they don't provide enough protection.
There's a very paternalistic culture
in conservatorship probate courts.
But what this means is that
the person who's under conservatorship,
essentially ceases to
exist as a legal entity.
The conservator takes away
any possibility of
decision making, legally.
We've had situations in
which the conservator
not only controls the money
and the living situation,
but also whether or not to
go to religious observances,
whether the individual is able to see
or refuse to see family members,
and whether the individual
is able to marry
or make medical decisions.
Next slide, and I'm gonna do it this time.
From the ACLU perspective,
we care about this because it is the most
complete deprivation of civil liberties
aside from the death penalty,
which Claude Pepper acknowledged in
congressional review of
this issue years ago.
But we have made fairly
little progress since then.
From a parent's perspective,
civil liberties probably
aren't that important.
What's much more important is the way that
the conservatorship will
affect the child's life.
We've already gone through...
We've already gone through
the fact that the court
appoints the conservator.
But I should also point out
that the court can remove the conservator.
We have had situations in which
the court has appointed a parent
because that was the plan for the family.
But then the parent is resisting
what the court is
ordering the parent to do,
and decides, "okay fine. I'm
removing you as conservator,
and I'm appointing a
professional conservator."
Professional conservators often don't have
a lot of time to get
to know the individual.
They often go by rote,
and often will default to
institutional placements
when other options aren't easy.
The other piece is that,
for many of the population
that we're most interested in,
folks with developmental disabilities,
decision making can increase with time.
Conservatorship may be
something that isn't
that bad at the beginning,
when it's imposed when the
individual is 18 or 19.
But it's not something
that's easy to reverse.
Courts really, really don't like
taking someone out from
under a conservatorship
once it's in place.
That person at 40 or 45 may
be living independently,
may be working at a job almost full time,
but is still under conservatorship.
We've worked with folks in this situation
and found it very difficult to get them
out from under the conservatorship.
Again, from the parent's perspective,
this isn't just a
problem in the long term,
it's also a problem in
terms of what is best
for the individual.
For the individual's perspective
it's a problem in terms of
what's best for the individual.
We all learn how to make
decisions by making mistakes.
We all learn how to make decisions by
practicing making decisions.
If someone is making the decisions for you
that skill is much harder to develop.
It may not develop.
Most studies that have looked at this
show that folks who have that practice,
who have been able to
exercise decision making
and self-determination,
are in fact better able
to protect themselves
from abuse or neglect.
They know who to go to,
they know who to ask,
they know how to say no.
Let's talk for a few moments
about supported decision-making.
Does anyone want to try
and define it for me?
Brave soul?
You wouldn't be wrong, because
(audience laughs)
supported decision-making
has so many definitions.
It's a very broad category.
What we like about it most at the ACLU
is that it allows people with disabilities
to retain their legal status,
to retain their civil liberties.
The idea is that an individual chooses
one to sometimes three or more
people who they trust
to help them with the
process of making decisions.
Because it is a less restrictive
alternative to conservatorship,
under California law
we believe it should be tried
before imposing a conservatorship.
A little more about
supported decision-making.
The key piece of supported decision-making
is recognizing that we don't have
an on/off switch with capacity.
It's not all or nothing.
People's ability to make decisions
depend on the context,
depend on the issue,
depend on how they're doing
at that moment in time.
We all use supported decision-making.
I use it for everything from
making major medical decisions
to certainly what I'm gonna
do with my adolescent.
(audience laughs)
Even whether I'm gonna buy
these dining room chairs
versus those dining room chairs.
The idea behind
the more formal designation
of supported decision-making
for people with disabilities, is that
the agreement is recognized.
That both sides understand that
for these areas of decision making,
I'm gonna go to these people for advice.
There are formal documents
that can be signed.
We have examples of them on our website
on the ACLU, which is at
the end of your PowerPoint.
But we also have more
informal arrangements.
The good thing about
supported decision-making
is that you don't have to go to court,
and as your relationships change,
as your capacities change,
as your opinions and interests change,
you can change who is
providing you the advice,
who is providing you the support.
Some of the ways that we encourage people
to think about providing support
really breaks down into
how decisions are made.
Every decision has a goal.
That needs to be clear at the outset.
Then identifying options,
evaluating the pros and
cons of those options,
reminding the individual of
what values they bring to the decision,
and finally making the decision.
Supporters should be willing to help
with articulating any of
those first four issues:
what's the goal, what are the options,
pros and cons, what
are the values at play.
But the idea is that the individual
is the person who makes that fifth,
final step of what the final decision is.
Supporters also may be really key in
translating complicated
ideas into plain language.
One of the things that
we did at the ACLU is
translate powers of attorney
into plain language.
So powers of attorney for healthcare,
powers of attorney for finances,
permissions,
HIPPA releases translated
into plain language.
Permission to work with
the educational system
once a child is 18,
translated into plain language.
With these plain language documents,
almost anything that you
need legal authorization for
you can use and talk with
an individual with a disability through
if they want that support.
Finally, helping to
communicate wishes to others.
This may be because
the individual has cerebral palsy
and it is a skill that's developed
to be able to understand
what they're saying,
or it may be because of a lot
what Rudy was talking about
in that you've spent enough
time with the individual
that you have a better guesswork system
to be able to convey
their values and wishes.
How do we know if
supported decision-making
might work for the patients that you see?
The first step is to acknowledge
that there's a wide range of issues,
and we don't have a "yes"
or "no" for each of them.
The second is to help
them identify which areas
they might need support in
and help them find who they might
use to provide that support.
One of the things that I'm...
I'm glad that we're doing
pretty well with time.
I want to spend a fair
amount of time talking now
about a new tool for
competency evaluations.
Those of you who've done
competency evaluations,
what do you usually use to do them?
I really do want you to speak up.
Someone be brave.
(comment from man in audience)
- So you're talking about
a competency evaluation
for one particular decision,
and you try and make sure that
you understand that one decision.
Okay, great.
(comment from audience)
Great, okay.
Has anyone done competency evaluations
for a conservatorship?
(comment from woman in audience)
- In California, guardianship applies
to people under 18, youth,
and conservatorship applies
to people over 18, adults.
I'm talking about people over 18.
In the rest of the country,
guardianship generally applies to adults.
It's confusing for those
of us who work nationally.
(comment from woman in audience)
- Okay. That's really important
and we're gonna come back to that.
There's someone whose
hand was up back here.
(comment from woman in audience)
Their social situation.
Their past medical history.
Neurological exams.
Ability to communicate.
IQ exams.
(comment from woman in audience)
- Okay, thank you.
There's a good clarification
that's happened here,
the term of art that you use
is a competency evaluation
is competency to stand trial
and conservatorship evaluation
is a conservatorship evaluation.
All right, then let me change my language
because I'm talking about a
conservatorship evaluation.
The tools that I've usually seen
and that the courts have usually requested
are what you were saying of IQ exams,
various short term memory tests,
problem solving skills, et cetera.
They're usually tools that are done
in a relatively artificial
context in an office.
They're usually done without any support,
even if the person
generally does have support
in their daily life.
They aren't done with what decisions
an individual make
actually make day to day.
From our perspective as lawyers,
the ideal process would be
spending real time from dawn
to dusk with an individual,
walking with them through their life,
seeing at what points
they act independently,
at what points they act with support,
and at other points
someone else is intervening
because they are unable
to make a decision.
That would be something that
happens over a week or two.
Obviously the ideal approach is
administratively and
financially unfeasible.
That's not something we
can ask you to implement.
Was there a question?
(comment from woman in audience)
I don't want to miss what you're saying.
The folks who are in the overflow room
aren't gonna be able to hear you,
so I just want to try
and summarize quickly.
What you're saying is that
usually in New Jersey,
you're from New Jersey,
you've got two people doing this.
And you, as the
psychologist? Psychiatrist.
Want to do the functional assessment.
Quickly.
(comment from woman in audience)
And the hardest ones to
do are broad based. Right.
Let me just move on.
I'm hoping that this is in your packet.
There are two different forms.
One is for a physician and
one is for an individual
and/or individual and supporters.
They are essentially checklists.
This is a tool that the
Missouri Center on Excellence
and Disability began,
and that we have modified
and have been trying out.
This is version 2.0.
I expect we'll get to version 16.0
before we're satisfied with it.
But I wanted to review it with you
and ask for your help with this,
because we want you guys to be the ones
who are doing the evaluations
for conservatorships.
You are the ones who work with people
who have developmental disabilities.
You understand better
what the capacities are,
what the potential is.
You're gonna be less likely to
default to stereotypes
about limitations and the need for
a plenary conservatorship,
and more likely to identify that there are
many ways in which people who would
otherwise be put under conservatorship
could in fact use
supported decision-making.
It's very hard to put a
chart up on a PowerPoint,
but I want to pull this out for you
to highlight that there are
not yes/no columns here.
There are three columns.
On the left hand side
are the various areas...
Thank you, it's in the book. Good.
Various categories in which people
may or may not need support.
may or may not be able
to act independently.
One of the ways that we are hoping
to expand and change the way
these competency or conservatorship
evaluations are done,
is to have an individual
first fill this out for themselves
with any available support,
and talk through with
whomever is supporting them
which areas they are
able to do by themselves.
Maybe they're able to
communicate very effectively.
Maybe there is no problem with
them being able to understand
how they make choices.
But this moves from
communication, to personal care,
to staying safe, to home and friends,
and breaks each of these
areas down into small bits
so that you can have a conversation
with the individual about both
whether they do this by themselves,
whether they really don't do it at all,
or whether they might be
able to do it with support.
And if they could do it with support,
who that person might be.
I'm gonna just reemphasize
that this is a tool that we,
as attorneys,
want the courts to begin
to pay attention to.
This is a tool that we hope
will develop some
real life use to you
and to us when we are working with people
who may be put under conservatorship,
or may be eligible for
supported decision-making.
It's also a tool that can just help
in facilitating someone's independence.
It's a way of seeing which skills
might be able to be increased with support
and learned over time.
Let me just give a couple
more examples here.
For example, in transportation.
It may be that someone who is
going regularly to a job
or to a friend's house or to a store,
has learned that skill,
knows which bus to take,
knows where their Clipper Card is,
and knows the route or even what to do
if they miss their stop
and need to go backwards.
That would be a skill that
is fully independent, right?
There is no need for support.
But if they have a doctor's appointment,
or a specialist's appointment
that they haven't been to before,
it may be that
that is something that they
could figure out with support.
Someone reminds them of
the map and the route,
and talks about that with them beforehand.
Or it may be that for that one instance,
they need someone to go with them.
Or they need someone to order a taxi
to take them back and forth.
That's the kind of thing that,
as you work with in individual
who has a disability,
you can develop systems for
and avoid the types of crises that often
lead people to say, "this
person needs a conservatorship.
This person can't be
living independently."
I'm going to reiterate that
I recognize that
folks here are prone to
support independence. Thank you.
They're prone to support
supported decision-making.
Thank you.
But just because that's your bent,
doesn't mean we don't want you doing
conservatorship evaluations.
When we have cases that are brought to us,
the people who've done the
conservatorship evaluations
always find that this person
needs to be under conservatorship.
We need folks who can present
counter-balancing evidence
that there are ways in which
this person can function
and can at least try
supported decision-making
before we condemn them to what is
the greatest deprivation
of civil liberties
aside from the death penalty.
Questions.
(question from woman in audience)
Thank you, yeah.
We need to move to the next one
and have some conversation afterward,
but I'm very glad you brought that up
because you're absolutely right
that the intent behind conservatorships
and even the language
of what direction the
conservatorship is given
is one of collaboration
and one of representing
the individual's interest.
That is absolutely what
many, many conservators do
for the ward.
I do not mean to impugn what really good,
really helpful people are trying to do.
At the same time, legally,
if the individual disagrees
with the conservator,
there is no recourse.
There's no recourse.
Legally, that person is essentially
at the whim and mercy of the conservator.